get ready for some serious Burns and the
instantaneous death of organisms
let's turn up the heat and bring the
entire planet to a boil for five whole
seconds
apocalyptic Heat Wave affect the
environment
what would this do to all living things
on earth
and would you be doomed to explode from
the inside out
this is what if and here's what would
happen if the Earth reached the boiling
point for five seconds
while you might complain about roasting
in the blistering heat of a summer day
the average temperature on Earth is
around 13.9 degrees Celsius
compare that to the hottest places on
the planet like China's flaming
mountains or Iran's Lut desert which
have recorded land temperatures around
70 degrees Celsius
and that's still not nearly as hot as a
cup of boiling hot tea
water reaches its boiling point at 100
degrees Celsius
this is the point where liquid water
turns into water vapor
with 71 of the earth's surface covered
in water life is about to feel like
you're stuck inside one giant kettle
if temperatures suddenly spiked you know
you wouldn't necessarily need to worry
about everything going up in Flames yeah
at least not right away
wood ignites at around 300 degrees
Celsius
and while you could be imagining that
all the water in the oceans would
suddenly boil away
don't worry that wouldn't happen either
that's because the deeper you go into
the ocean the higher the pressure
and this affects the boiling temperature
already at 10 meters below the water
surface the boiling point becomes closer
to
120 degrees Celsius
so not all the ocean water on Earth
would turn into vapor but in the steamy
shallow Waters most living organisms
plants and animals would likely spend
these five seconds boiling to death
maybe only thermophiles microorganisms
that thrive at temperatures up to 108
degrees Celsius would survive unscathed
and you wouldn't enjoy this brief
apocalyptic window of time very much
either
the steam would scald your skin and
seriously injure your eyes
even just taking a breath during this
time could cause mucous membranes in
your mouth nose and throat to suffer
severe burns
if these Burns were deep enough to
destroy tissues you could end up
developing rhabdomyolysis
this condition could result in permanent
damage to your heart and kidneys or even
death
but that's not even the worst
there's also a lot of ready to boil
water somewhere else
in your body
yeah you are about 60 water if this
water was to turn into steam
you'd know it your body's water would
suddenly increase in volume by 1600
times
well you and anything else that has
water inside it would simply explode
from the inside out
but maybe you'd be lucky in five seconds
wouldn't be long enough to detonate you
well that wouldn't mean that life
following the worst Heat Wave imaginable
would go right back to normal
no immediately after the five seconds
the global temperatures would
drastically drop
and all that water vapor would transform
back into liquid
you'd better be prepared for some crazy
flash flooding and extreme weather
and that steam turning back into water
would bump the temperatures in the
surrounding environment
things could heat back up enough that
polar ice caps and Glaciers would melt
even faster
when all that ice disappeared the sea
levels would rise by about 70 meters
so even though the Earth would only have
boiled for about the same amount of time
it takes for one big yawn
it would create circumstances where
major cities around the world could
become flooded and uninhabitable
millions of people could die in the
aftermath
and that's if they didn't already turn
into spontaneous steam bombs
okay why don't we cool things down for
five seconds instead
all the way down to absolute zero
well
that's a story
for another
what if
[Music]